ANI LIU: I like to
challenge my audience
with sensory experiences that
can almost feel threatening.
[dramatic electronic music]
I always use hair,
spit, semen, blood.
Why do you find it disgusting?
Why is that normal?
Why are things so sanitized?
I think as an artist I'm
really interested in all things
sensory, especially as
it relates to perception.
And with things like virtual
reality and augmented reality,
it's so interesting
that you can kind
of reprogram that perception.
So the empathy machines are a
set of headsets that allowed
two people to swap vision.
They're equipped with
tiny cameras that they use
for drones, actually,
and video glasses,
and they're programmed with
radio frequency to swap feeds.
So you could look
out through my eyes
and I would look
out through yours.
When you look at something,
light bounces off that object
and reflects into
your retina and it
becomes-- processes the image.
But when you smell something,
a molecule of that substance
binds into your receptor and, in
my mind, becomes a part of you.
The project Human Perfume
started very ambitiously
with the goal of
growing a plant that
could always create the
scent profile of someone that
had loved and lost.
And it turns out it was a
very complicated process.
But along the way, I learned
a lot of other techniques
which allowed me to create
a chemical reamalgamation
of someone's smell.
First, I take someone's
shirt or garment
that they've been wearing
for a really long time
and then I cut strips of
it that are the stinkiest
and I put them in a solvent.
And then I distill it from
very traditional ways,
like with glassware.
There's something so
inherently sensual about smell.
I think in the current
landscape that we're in,
it's really important
to come back
to these sensual experiences.
I really love revealing
the invisible, actually,
everything from the microscopic
scale to the, I guess,
telescopic scale.
With the microbial pieces that
are self-portraits that I grew
from my body, I was really
interested in forces
that co-make me beyond myself.
I was talking to
a microbiologist
and he was telling me about the
microbiome for the first time
and I was so blown away.
For every 10 cells in your body,
nine of them are not your own.
They're invisible,
but basically live
on every surface of your
body and influence everything
from your behavior to your mood
and it's such an integral part
of who you are.
I started to grow
my own cultures
just to see what they were.
What do they look
like from my armpit?
What do they smell like?
What do they look like
from my belly button?
What does it look
like from my partner?
You use agar,
which is a gelatin,
and put in a bunch of nutrients
and you set into a jelly
into a Petri dish.
I would dip a sterile Q-tip
in DI water and then plate it.
And then you incubate it,
which means you keep it
nice and toasty at the
perfect temperature
that it wants to be at.
I had always thought of myself
as a nature versus nurture kind
of paradigm.
But the fact that
a totally different
organism could also co-make
me was really fascinating.
I think it's especially
important in the technological
landscape to include
artists because, you know,
scientists and technologists
strive so hard to make
the world a better place.
And so much of what I strive
to do is ask, what is better?
Who is better?
Who is it better for?
Is it better for you, for
me, for a child, for a man?
These are really
charged questions
that I think artists
can fearlessly
ask when they use these media.